begin sufre el peor brote desde que
empezó la pandemia los casos han subido
en los últimos tres días desde los 600 a
los 1000 hasta los 1400 y eso a pesar de
las crecientes restricciones hoy Beijing
ha cerrado centros comerciales museos y
parques y además impone una cuarentena
de tres días a todos los que llegan a la
ciudad el viernes ya había empezado a
cerrar bares y restaurantes que ahora
solo pueden servir comida a domicilio
además muchos lugares públicos exigen
una prueba pcr realizada en las últimas
24 horas en contraste con las 72
habituales lo que explica las largas
colas Para hacerse los test de Jim vive
en un estado de semicocinamiento con
cada vez más complejos inmobiliarios
puestos en cuarentena ninguna de las
noticias que llega desde la capital son
positivas este fin de semana se informó
de tres muertos todos ellos octogenarios
y con enfermedades previas pero son los
primeros muertos por Kobe que china en
seis meses es también la primera vez en
ese plazo que el país roza los 30.000
casos diarios fue en aquel brote
gigantesco que obligó a cerrar Shanghai
durante casi tres meses Pero la
situación ahora es más preocupante
porque los contagios están repartidos
por varias ciudades en el caso de
chonchin en el centro o de wanjoo en el
sur que no han podido en bridar sus
brotes durante semanas a pesar de todas
las restricciones aprobadas